Rôm nay, ở đây cũng ngày hôm nay, có một mô đả phải điều động tiêm kích sau khi một ua vê bị cá vôc là con gà,
sấm nhập sâu hơn 1,5 k clay mẹ vào con phản đồ mà đi, đánh dấu vụ bị phạm nhêm cho nát kể từ khi sống độ ua quay nà khơi phát.
Mô chừng cuo phòng đồ mà đi, ổ t most tần nếu cho biết, các vý công nát tôi đã cần nhắc bản hạ của vê nhưng không khai hoa,
giòn lo ngại mạnh bữa gây thiệt hại giữa mặt đất. Mạnh bữa không chưa chất nổ sau đó được tìm thấy trên lạnh thổ đồ mà đi.
Theo Bucarès sau khi thấy ua vê,
em rau phải tờ đã được phía đất chình Khá chất,
tìm đích theo xa ua vê, hả ter ca, chức khi nổ quay là ua quay nà.
R верa đo sau đó vý nhận Buc sơm lập thứ 2 ở hạn gà là ti y kìa and rô mà đi đyều term 2 amy sau cũng 2 em rau phải tờ ca.
Ua vê sau đó bây giờ tật, branches Kia牠 Binh giỏi hơn 100 km,
buộc nhiều người dân địa phương phát chú 1 tạm thôi.
Đây là lần thống ngày 3. Rô mà đi nghĩ nhận ua vê Binh giỏi kể từ năm 2009 và là lần đầu tiên giữa bằng ngày.
Tưởng Christopher đến ở Huy lực lượng Mỹ tại NATO cho biết Washington sẽ trên khai năng lực bánh trạc
UAV mới tại Vũm Châu Thổ, sống đả nước.
Tại vắc sơ và phát biểu về sự viện, Mũch vẫn còn vá là đi sọc,
có sinh nắc kêu gọi NATO lấy nháng tăng tự phòng về trước mỗi người hiểm của UAV ở sơn đông.
Châu dàng sự gấu tại Rôm Nhi Châu Thái như cầu cơm bách của họ đậm nay.